Esto es lo que parece la primera Cumbre
china hacia central rodeado por los
presidentes de cinco exe repúblicas
soviéticas kazajistán kirguistán
tayikistán turkmenistán y Uzbekistán el
presidente chino aseguró que las
relaciones entre Beijing Y estos cinco
países han entrado en una nueva era
repasamos la historia de los
intercambios amistosos entre China y
Asia central revisamos los resultados de
nuestros compromisos resumimos las
experiencias exitosas y construimos un
nuevo consenso juntos firmamos la
declaración de
un símbolo porque la ciudad está situada
en el extremo oriental de la antigua
ruta de la seda las nuevas rutas de la
seda se pusieron en marcha a finales de
2013 desde ese entonces china ha gastado
miles de millones de dólares para
desarrollar puertos ferrocarriles e
infraestructuras en el extranjero
especialmente en los cinco países
invitados
sabe que por la guerra de Rusia en
Ucrania
Moscú ha perdido su influencia con los
antiguos miembros de la Unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas y
Beijing pretende aprovecharse de esta
brecha coincidencia del calendario o no
esta primera Cumbre china Asia central
se celebra al mismo tiempo que la del g7
Hiroshima una china que a los ojos de su
gran rival americano es más que nunca
una amenaza mundial